[Music]
it may be a global pandemic
but when it comes to individual nations
the response has been anything but
uniform
while some governments were quick to
implement lockdowns and mask wearing
others only reacted when the virus had
already wreaked havoc
the crisis has exposed major
philosophical divides
over the questions like the role of
government or the definition of
individual responsibility
as a result outcomes have varied greatly
but the experience of some countries has
also helped shape the response of others
in this time of crisis what can we learn
from each other
[Music]
welcome to your covet 19 special i'm
chris colbert in berlin
germany has gone into a second hard
coronavirus lockdown
with all non-essential shops schools and
daycares closed
the move comes after less stringent
measures failed to break a second wave
of infections
now even after months governments still
seem to be pondering over how to best
battle the virus
the south american country of uruguay
seems to have found a viable way
this year has been a stressful time for
the delbracio mayo family in montevideo
guillermo was born two weeks before the
start of the lockdown
in itself a joyful occasion but they
couldn't share it with anyone
or get any help because anna christina
del brasio and her husband martine
along with the children had to go into
quarantine
there was a suspected case of covet 19
in their circle of friends
it was terrible for us because the
grandmothers couldn't come
nor the grandfathers or my brothers no
one could come and meet the baby
it was really tough now
seven months later the world looks very
different
the borders between uruguay and its
neighbours are still closed
but the small country is so far doing
well with less than a hundred deaths
and only a few thousand cases overall
although infections have now risen
sharply again
schools and universities closed for a
few weeks in the spring
it was the same for shops but now the
streets are busy again
many people voluntarily wear masks in
public
there's still a need for caution but
there's also an obvious sense of relief
that things are not worse than they are
the mood is also upbeat at the pasteur
research institute
when the pandemic started in march they
were able to respond immediately with
nationwide testing
the testing kits came from these
laboratories they say the approach taken
by the government
helped
i think one of the big advantages in
uruguay compared to other countries
was that both the president and his
coronavirus team
supported our scientists right from the
start so that the scientists were then
able to make decisions in good time
for decades uruguay has invested in its
welfare state
and that appears to be paying off now in
the crisis
the country is home to around 3.5
million people
poverty is still definitely an issue in
some areas
and impossible to overlook in the
capital
uruguay's former president jose mourika
is one of those credited with reducing
the gap between
rich and poor during his five years in
office he was president until 2015
and invested heavily in health education
and social welfare
now 85 years old he agreed to give us an
interview at his home
a certain level of prosperity allowed us
to develop a social democracy
that has shaped the entire country in
material not only structurally and
materially
but also in terms of our way of life
[Music]
we are now a country known for its
tolerance where people are very
civilized in their dealings with each
other
also when there are differences of
opinion or economic crises
back to the del brazil family they've
been enjoying meeting regularly with
relatives and friends again
so what do they think is the secret of
uruguay's relative success in the crisis
so far
apart from good political decisions they
think the country just got lucky to a
certain extent
perhaps it's a different mutation of the
virus that we have here that means the
cases aren't as bad as in europe
or perhaps it's the climate the air in
the scene
foreign i have no idea
there must be some other reason
a few months ago they never thought
their lives would improve again so
quickly
but none of them will forget the anxious
period around guillermo's birth
anytime soon let's get more on the
uruguayan way and whether it can serve
as a model for others with marika
blowfield she's the director of the
latin
america division at the german institute
for global and area studies
she joins me by a skype from hamburg
welcome to dw america
latin america and the caribbean have
been heavily hit by the pandemic and its
economic ramifications
what really has uruguay done better so
far to cope with the crisis
well uruguay had a better health care
and social infrastructure going
into the pandemic and so when the
pandemic hit the government was well
prepared to mobilize its
state infrastructure to help with both
the health response
and make sure that populations were able
to stay inside shelter a home
and still feed their families and the
current government is also
following uruguayan's uruguay's very
institutionalized tradition a unifier
has been
unifying rather than
divisive and the population trusts the
government so they did as the government
said
uh and finally uruguay also had a
pioneering
veering via urologist who
was able to with colleagues invent his
own
test and that helped with massive rapid
testing
right from the beginning and so i think
those three factors have been very
important in helping uruguay
whether the pandemic much better than
any other latin american country
so in your opinion what is the takeaway
here for other countries
particularly those that might have less
money to spare for a solid
health care system there is
no better prevention than being well
prepared also from a social
social infrastructure point of view i
mean governments simply need to invest
more resources in building a basic
universal
welfare state which includes health care
and emergency income provision
now since november daily new infection
numbers have been rising
drastically and are now peaking in
uruguay what happened there
well i think i'm not an epidemiologist
but i think what happened there is also
happening in germany all over europe and
north america and so uruguay is now
being spared from this second wave
i think the rates are still lower than
they are in germany for example i think
currently icu capacity is about 56
in uruguay so they're still doing okay
and i believe that they're going to
announce stronger measures
uh today now they've never had a
mandatory lockdown like many other latin
american countries
had and they've announced they don't
plan to do that but they do plan to
exhort their citizens
to behave well and responsibly through
the christmas holidays just like
germany has done in many ways uruguay's
path is not
so different from germany's path now
you're
an expert on latin america what exactly
needs to be done to protect people at
high risk of social disadvantage during
a pandemic you absolutely have to ensure
that they have the means to stay home
and isolate and that's where
there is no easy solution except
investing socially more for the future
and
it was a rude awakening for most of
latin america when the pandemic
happened and governments told their
citizens to stay home
and most citizens could not do that
because they simply didn't have the
means to support themselves through the
pandemic and there's been a lot of rapid
state building going on
in the region to try to reach these
disadvantaged populations and the
governments that have done that are
probably in a better position
to whether the next pandemic or the next
economic crisis
but it does take effort and investment
and i think that's the only way that
governments can can
weather these pandemics without
devastating human
human impacts marika blowfield director
of the giga institute for latin america
studies
thank you for your insights thank you
and now it is time to answer your
questions about the coronavirus
here's our science correspondent derek
williams
what does the latest data say about how
much schools and universities contribute
to community spread
this sounds like one question but it's
actually two so
so let's split it up kids and schools
first there's been conflicting
information
on just how common transmission is among
children
but in general the current consensus
is that unlike in other respiratory
diseases
schools aren't really driving the spread
of covet 19.
at the beginning of this week national
geographic
reported exclusively on a major news
study from iceland
and and said that its conclusions were
that kids under 15
are only around half as likely to
transmit the virus as adults are
that data hasn't been published yet but
if the report
is correct it would provide
corroborating evidence
for a phenomenon that many experts
now accept which is that the older a
child is
the more infectious they are if they
themselves contract covet 19
we still don't really know why but but
outbreaks
in high schools for example are
happening at a much
higher rate than they are in elementary
schools
so what about universities well college
students
are physiologically adults and they seem
to transmit
like other adults do 20 year olds
are not the ones who are most in danger
if they catch the virus but they can
apparently have a big
impact on its spread in the wider
community
although it's hard to put an exact
number on that impact
an analysis carried out by the new york
times
showed that in communities throughout
the u.s for instance
deaths in counties that were home to
universities
and large populations of college
students are consistently outstripping
deaths
in counties without them but those
deaths are not happening
among the college students they're
happening among older people in those
communities
who are getting covet 19 in greater
numbers in those counties
so what the data is telling me at least
so far is that while schools
tend to reflect spread in a community um
they don't drive it universities on the
other hand
appear to do that possibly in a big way
you